[Musique]
détails
effroyable incendie harly photos et
rohmer daniélou fils de jean françois
daniellou de gaitan la reagan il ougna
vendée dans le finistère est heureux
aujourd'hui de vous vendre france soir
un régal de lecture un sensationnel
aujourd'hui effroyable à incendie à orly
photos des tags
la vente est arrêté pendant quelques
instants mais jamais arrivé de trouver
mal à ça c'est pas facile depuis 25 ans
je n'ai jamais manqué une journée dans
mon travail
sauf les jours de grève le 1er mai 25
ans de métier dur et difficile
c'est beaucoup et pourtant robert
daniélou n'a rien perdu de son
enthousiasme
j'arrive à la gare du nord de la gare du
nord je viens à pied naturellement ça me
détend et puis je vois mes amis du matin
tout ça ensuite je vais prendre mon
petit champagne ça c'est immuable à 100
pas dit s'il vous plaît deux doigts là
n'est parfait
[Musique]
j'arrive au journal
je vais chercher le quotidien il ya des
jours où vraiment ces quotidiens son
épée il s'engage sur c'est mon matériel
au travail c'est à dire le mardi ou le
foprodi 250 grammes le quotidien je suis
obligé de prendre mes dispositions type
de tabac le casque est en train puis à
20 ans nous prenons 300 ou 350 jours
nous a si le sud ou que maintenant s'il
fallait les porter ça serait un calvaire
bon alors maintenant
genre dans les 50 à mon chef ainsi
commence la journée de travail d'un des
derniers crieur de journaux chargé sur
son dos 40 kg de papier 40 kg de
journaux qui ne suffit pas de porter il
faut aussi les vendre quelques uns
encore aujourd'hui à l'attaqué journal
c'est tout un journal que vous défendez
c'est un titre
j'ai la foi parce que gerra titre un
exemple qui saute et envers et contre
tout nous défendons c'est dans le
quartier du faubourg saint nic avec un
goût très prononcé pour les contacts
humains
robert daniélou vend ses journaux mais
comment devient de ton vendant de
journaux quand je suis revenue dans le
vendeur de jours où ça a été je me
retrouvais un rêve sans travail il y
avait des ventes de la trousse qui
sortait déjà rencontré un certain
journalisme
c'était monsieur lazhar est il était
journaliste
or là je connais deux séries d'ados
ligue 1 mais vous voulez faire le
vendeur de journaux
papy je dis pourquoi pas mais ça c'est
fait
maintenant le bouton france soir alors
les ptt ça marche
oui ça va les ptt
comment va à lui c'est un auvergnat
ça se voit je sais pas les bénéfices de
fin d'année encore monsieur et avocats
la cour d'appel de paris
charmettes vous allez bien ce
journaliste me dit monsieur nous est
très bien si vous voulez remontée
appareils il donne son adresse
j'avais rien j'avais tout perdu par les
bombardements
sam alouettes en brûler tous mes biens
étant saint malo j'avais plus rien du
tout une petite valise c'était su
surmonter à paris mon petit chou la
croix ce jour et tu vas lèveront le
lendemain matin sans connaître de
tourner sans rien du tout j'avais tout
vendu m'appelant pas le bâton canard ah
là là vous savez ces gens là ils sont
impatients
voilà le v'là le sensationnel voilà
france soir qu'est ce qu'il faut pas
peur ici alors qu'as tu me perrin
l'autre jour à chez pas le temps qui me
perds un autre jour ça ça se lève et
monte monte lui vivant il attend après
son canard allez vas-y jean sulem
sensationnel comment que sa vache a
remis il va la boxe purificateur
seigneur mon esprit
au revoir à demain au dessus curé je
vous plaisir au revoir tous les matins
c'est comme ça je vais entendre débrief
on l'entend de loin arrivé écrit
sensationnel alors quand on entend vers
son bichon soit bon phénomène du
quartier tout le monde aime bien il met
l'ambiance
la vrai titi quoi c'est le vieux paris
ça fait un peu partie du faubourg saint
denis une assez petite amie ses copines
les petites vieilles du quartier qu'ils
connaissent bien
toujours un petit mot il en fait le
bisou tout commence à la capitaine ça va
bien et je suis gâté comment savez-vous
samaa et votre dame m'a pas porté nous
tenons à le canard jeunes prendront pas
son homme allez allez en route capitaine
marchent marchent marchent jonah hill au
bataillon bataillon qui n'a au fond dans
la musique
moi je chante toujours et croyez moi
quand je chante dans la rue eh bien je
suis sûr par moments que certaines
personnes sont touchées par ma gaieté
[Musique]
il n'a pas
voyons
vous avez des événements qui m'ont outre
passer outre pressé comme edith piaf
combien de fois que edith piaf n'a donné
un billet quand je travaillais à
l'olympia pour vendre les journaux et
mon petit chou tu vois un billet sncf et
les choses ont vraiment qu'on ne peut
pas oublier et et croyez-vous quand ces
gens-là disparaissent de notre vue tu es
mon est peiné parce que on a un gros
coeur de toutes ces choses là
c'était un petit peu notre vide rue on
comprenait la vie qu'on ressente tous
les jours c'est cesser cette guy cas
nous a donné parce qu'il faut le dire il
faut être franc c'est on disait la mode
de la rue et ben nous on est des mondes
de la rue la cre a hier dans sa caméra
et ceux d avec satisfaction le prieur de
sa crèmerie regarde avec dérogations
messieurs mesdames sur la vitrine d'un
hacker beurre d'isigny
mais moi qui venais via la chose c'est
autre chose on se met à l'aise il a les
ir les i also bon sens glisser ma vie ça
fait partie de ma vie c'est ma vie les
commerçants les gens de la rue on ne
peut pas s'imaginer ce que c'est ces
gens qui vous tiennent à coeur
ces gens qui se disent oui s'il vient
pas qu'est ce qui lui était arrivé mais
c'est vrai alors il m'arrive de faire
des faits divers où je ne passe pas eh
bien je suis sûr que les trois quarts de
mes clients ce jour-là n'achète pas leur
quotidien parce qu'ils veulent moi dans
la rue
vous avez des des enfants qui viennent
embrasser on se demande pourquoi parce
que c'est des enfants kim qui avait
alors eu leur petit sensationnel s'ils
nous avaient lieu alors les gars
décontracté vous quand vous marchez
serrer les rangs s'il vous plaît au delà
des façons comment que ça va mais chérie
ça va mon petit on va vous donner des
bonbons lundi à l'école comme d'habitude
sensationnel
au revoir mon petit chat ça va ça marche
tu vois comment va la musique ici encore
[Musique]
les jeunes et à leurs familles démunies
netapp chez les gars de paille
je suis là comme en bosnie
je suis vraiment le vrai que cela fait
des années que c'est comme ça sa formule
1 pour cent mais oui mesdames sur la
place de paris
je suis né dans le faubourg saint denis
une lewin d'abobo paris voit le jour je
vais arrêter et je le crois pas parce
que sincèrement ce jour là ça sera
terrible pour moi
on mettra peut-être derrière un kiosque
l'esa sera terrible le jour j'aurais pu
marquer à moi vous propose ma rue pour
moi je sais qui c'est
alors le jour je vais pu alors c'est
terminé pour moi je me sens à ma vie
sera terminé
[Musique]